moi ça me fait un peu rire déjà parce
que vous mettez face à quelqu'un quand
même qui fait partie du groupe en fils
antifa donc c'est un peu fort de café
venant d'un groupe de racailles
littéralement de rachat dont m bien sûr
la population consultée en plus vous
insultez militants identitaires ou pas
c'est pas nous qui avons des cas des
leaders des leaders team agrès sont
notamment sortis des gares donc s'il
vous plaît en charisme en survol matin à
lyon parce que j'aime dire ce que c'est
inventif à lyon c'est un groupe ultra
violent de racailles je vais juste
terminé de même les sessions avec papa
et maman tranquillement région le leader
des leaders hamas élu ni
en fait promeut directement sur ces
réseaux le groupe djihadiste boko haram
vous souvenez cette histoire d'accord
nominé capture voûté bien voir eh ben
vous dites quoi alors les favoris fonds
maître eric zemmour lui défend un groupe
djihadiste aux théories justement
jaillet j'allais y aller c'est parfait
par l'anti terrorisme on a des gens
comme eric zemmour qui s'érige en tant
que figure contre le terrorisme noah la
jeune garde à vue et notre
projet on lutte contre le terrorisme
nous il ya des caméras et conté henry a
déclaré pall théorie dit à des camarades
qui sont allés lutter a dit laura de
notre organisation contre des ch en
syrie d'accord mais pour botter des
camarades arabe kurde les ide qui ont
fait reculer dèche
chez les hommes aiment évincé d'accord
ça c'est mon camp politique qui perce et
commentés terrorisé donc c'est bon quoi
avons nous renvoyer d'ici là des
discours comme zemmour notamment avec
des tests comme le grand emplacement qui
poussent des militants d'extrême droite
notamment un mini toques séquelles qui
s'appelle logan cuisine il a eu un
procès lui contrairement à veut dire on
ne sait pas d'où ça va n'a rien à gagner
ou prêtés par militants formés à
l'action française un groupuscule
royalistes profondément antisémite qui
est d'ailleurs avec très proche d'eric
zemmour et compagnie rassurez vous savez
intérêts sa solution politique et s'est
passé aux attentats terroristes lui avec
tout ce corpus idéologique là il s'est
dit avec ses petits copains on va
attaquer des mousses qu'on va attaquer
des mosquées on va attaquer jean luc
mélenchon il a dès lors été installé à
n'a rien ne dit encore eric zemmour et
la nuit les gens veulent dire ces camps
notamment comme le remplacement pousse
des gens aujourd'hui aux attentes ans et
ça c'est très grave on va faire un très
très grave un petit
poucet les gens aux attentes avocat ya
cgt brandit en entier origin va
combattre ce que
j'essaie de dire que eric zemmour aura
même des gros sujets ça n'a rien à voir
avec eric zemmour vous vous caillassé du
cateau du flic métiers ouvrant ses
débuts et mes pieds mais at all my man
on voit sa saison ce samedi 27 à visage
ouvert pendant petit copain devant leurs
locaux étaient eric d'éviter à l'avenir
avec l'arménie tout cela est dans
l'intérêt
de tout ce qui bouge en virulence
zemmour trouble leur mobile ma chance
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est pourquoi à chaque fois qu'eric
zemmour se déplacent pourquoi ils créent
des émeutes pourquoi il se fait insulter
la réponse est simple parce que ses
idées sont nauséabondes et qu'elle
divise la société donc au bout d'un
moment quand on passe son temps à dire
qu'il ya des bons des mauvais et
étranger qu'il faut pas s'appeler
mohamed il faut interdire le mariage aux
homosexuels etc il faut pas s'étonner
légitimiser la violence légitime pas la
violence et on en a marre et ici au nom
du soldat contre l'eire ont laissé
parler les gens cette pâte la violence
peut guérir et physique mais elle peut
être aussi verbale et je pense qu'avec
les idées d'eric zemmour il ya des
millions de gens qui se sentent agressés
au plus profond d'eux mêmes donc je ne
cautionne pas la violence ne faut pas
s'étonner quand on dit des trucs de ouf
tout le temps à la télé et dans les
discours que quand on va au contact des
gens il se passe des choses parce
qu'avant